so I mentioned this yesterday briefly
but now I want to dig into it more that
we're starting to get actual results
from the Iowa caucus Democratic
candidate mayor Pete Budaj is getting
absolutely crushed for having declared
victory in Iowa Monday night before any
votes were really counted you might
remember that when there was about 1 or
2 percent of the vote in on Monday
before all vote reporting stopped
because of the fiasco involving the app
being used to communicate results in
Iowa Budaj edge was ahead for about 30
minutes by a couple points than it went
to Bernie but it was meaningless because
we had no results at the time and Mayor
Pete came out and gave a victory speech
and said check out this video but we
know by the time it's all said and done
Iowa you have shocked the nation and
then take a look at you know that this
is a victory speech and there were not
yet any actual vote counts because
tonight an improbable hope became an
undeniable reality
[Applause]
[Music]
it's actually making me cringe there we
just didn't have a count and he's
basically giving a victory speech now
Amy Klobuchar did a speech as well but
she was just kind of positive she wasn't
really implying or saying she won or
even doing anything close to claiming
victory and then Buddha a judge went on
to say on Twitter quote Iowa you have
shocked the nation by all indications we
are going on to New Hampshire victorious
hashtag Iowa caucuses now based on the
data we have as of this filming Pete
Buddha judge does have a slight lead
over Bernie Sanders but there are
essentially two possibilities for what
took place here and we're going to
discuss both of them he's getting
crushed the hashtag mayor cheat was
trending on Twitter he went on CBS
yesterday morning trying to explain
himself here's what he said the Sanders
campaign also saying they're essentially
victorious there are people online
saying that your claim of using the V
word is uh I think the hashtag is mayor
cheat in retrospect you think it was a
little premature to take the stage and
use the V word no I mean looking at what
happened last night looking at all of
the data that we've got it was an
extraordinary night and we are
absolutely victorious coming into New
Hampshire I mean this is a campaign that
when we launched a year ago people said
you're not a senator you're not a
national name now he still didn't have
any results at the time that interview
was filmed and he's insisting that he's
victorious coming into New Hampshire so
he was kind of doubling down and also
backtracking kind of saying well listen
what I didn't mean I literally won what
I meant was that given the odds against
a mayor from a small town in Indiana as
a general thing regardless of the vote
totals I'm victorious merely because I
got some delegates and so I see myself
as victorious moving on to New Hampshire
so there's two possibilities here one is
that this is like a super grifter II
consultant idea some consultant came up
with hey let's just go out and claim
victory and then there will be headlines
and you'll do a speech and later we can
reinterpret it as I just meant that for
a small-town mayor to get delegates
that's a win we don't even need to know
the vote totals and in fact mayor Pete
was sore
drifter consultant himself so maybe it
was actually his own idea to do it the
real problem here is that this doesn't
stop with Mayor Pete in Iowa once
candidates get into this idea of just
claiming victory even before there are
votes no matter what you are opening the
door to candidates claiming they won the
Democratic nomination multiple
candidates claiming that they won even
if it hasn't actually been decided you
can get to November 3rd and Donald Trump
claiming he won even before we have the
actual numbers and then that becomes
what Trump supporters believe even if
later it turns out actually you didn't
win someone else won well but Trump came
out and said he claimed victory it's a
disastrous path to be going down and
this is 2020 American America that's the
unfortunate reality and we have to be
prepared for a version of this in
November and even for the lead-up to the
eventual Domini nominee on the
Democratic side to have this type of
victory claim absent actual evidence now
there's another side to this and we're
gonna dig into this more in a little bit
there is the idea because a connection
has been found between a consultancy
group working on the Iowa caucus
and mayor Pete there's the idea that the
reason mayor Pete went out and claimed
victory was because he already knew that
the vote counts would be manipulated in
his favor and he would ultimately reign
victorious now I think it's important
that you know we find connections on
Republican sides and sometimes they're
meaningful and sometimes they're not and
what you really have to understand is
that in the incestuous world of politics
and power in the United States it's not
surprising to keep running into the same
people frequently and we have to be more
discerning than that right when Trump
says he doesn't know left Parnas and
Parnas keeps showing up in videos
talking to Trump about Murray Ivanovich
and whatever else at a certain point it
starts to be like radula T when it comes
to the mayor Pete thing I don't think
that we should attribute to malice what
be explained by incompetence but I am
not saying there is definitively nothing
to see here when it comes to these
consultant groups and mayor Pete let's
talk about that more in the next segment
because it is it's important that we get
this sort of under control before people
go too far with it I know that the David
Pakman show audience is full of curious
and creative people who love learning
new things and bettering themselves and
that's why I'm so excited to tell you
about one of our sponsors Skillshare the
vibrant online learning community that
offers thousands of classes on almost
any topic you can imagine and you'll get
full access to the entire library of
classes for two entire months free when
you go to david pakman.com slash skill
all of the classes are taught by experts
in their fields they've got classes on
drawing painting photography video
editing web design bookkeeping marketing
personal productivity doesn't even
scratch the surface I recently took a
class about photography if anybody
follows me on instagram you know that my
photography skills leave much to be
desired and it was great I got so much
out of it and hopefully you will see the
fruits of me taking that class reflected
in my Instagram pictures sooner than
later they have classes for every skill
level whether you're wanting to get
better at something you already have
experience with you want to learn
something totally new to you you set
your own pace classes are usually less
than an hour long they're divided up
into bite-size segments so you can
easily fit them into your schedule make
2020 a year where you explore new skills
deep in existing passions get lost in
creativity Skillshare really makes it
easier than ever
Skillshare memberships are less than ten
bucks a month and that gives you access
to the thousands of classes they offer
but everybody in the David Pakman show
audience gets a Skillshare membership
totally free for two whole months just
go to david pakman.com slash skill
that's david pakman.com slash s ki ll